one of the things you've done very
beautifully
is to communicate love and i think about
you know some of our conversations and
you got me to talk a little bit about my
own experiences and
3 8 and 3 9.
we are the product of our trauma
and what people don't understand is that
very often when you see
people taking countermeasures against
what appear to be imaginary forces
they're really actually replaying things
that really happen to them
and having been through this system and
watching all of the ways in which
it completely rewrites the lives of the
people who i'm counting on to cure our
diseases build our new industries keep
us safe from our foes
the amount of pressure the system is
putting on the
most hopeful minds is unimaginable
and so my my goal is to empower somebody
like
aaron schwartz in memory
you